CHONGSA KIM: Hi everyone.
My name is Chongsa Kim.
I lead Google Play
Games Partnership
for the Japanese
market in Tokyo.
As you may know, Japan is
one of the largest markets
in the space of mobile
gaming, and that is
true for Google Play as well.
Looking at successful games in
the Japanese market [INAUDIBLE]
is actually playing
a a very big role,
and the developers
are putting it
at the center of
their growth strategy.
And more interestingly, what
they're doing for LiveOps
is sometimes quite unique,
[INAUDIBLE] and [INAUDIBLE]
from those in the
Western regions.
So today I'm going to talk about
the greatest trends of LiveOps
in Japan, and also
share key insights
and best practices
learned from there.
So here's today's
agenda for you.
So first of all,
I'm going to talk
about what LiveOps
is, and explain
why it's important for
you as game developers.
And then I'm going to explain
a bit about a key market
difference between Japan
and Western Europe,
and then move onto the
case studies from Japan
and the lessons
learned from there.
So what is LiveOps?
I think many of you have already
heard of this definition,
but LiveOps is running
games as a service.
The characteristics
of the smartphone
as an always connected
device actually
allow the game developers
to frequently interact
with the end users by
providing additional content
and information as a service,
which does not necessarily
involve traditional APK updates.
So when these services are
provided in the right way,
it actually drives
user engagement,
stimulates monetization,
and even reduces
player turn, which has a
significant impact on the life
cycle of your game.
So what happens when
the service is not
enough for your end users?
So this is the typical
revenue trend curve
that games that deliver content
only via traditional APK
updates, but not via LiveOps.
For each update, you see
some spikes in revenue,
but it slows down pretty fast,
and you cannot maintain active
users by the next update, and
the spike size gets smaller
and smaller each time.
We call this a shark
fin [INAUDIBLE] problem,
and obviously this is
not ideal if you want
to make your game sustainable.
So in what way does
LiveOps solve this problem?
So LiveOps is basically
a strategic distribution
of frequent content updates
in between traditional APK
updates.
These are basically categorized
into two things, the sales
and events, and both of them
often contain a new content
into your game economy.
And typically these are provided
in a limited time basis, which
is a key for you to motivate
your users to participate
actively in the activity that
is happening inside our game.
When these sales and events
are provided in the right way,
LiveOps can drive a consistent
heartbeat of revenue
and engagement,
and which helps you
to avoid shark fin [INAUDIBLE]
problem for your game.
So that is LiveOps.
And from here I like to touch
a bit about the key market
difference between Japan
and Western Europe,
what's unique about Japan
in the context of LiveOps.
So first of all, Japan is a
really LiveOps heavy market,
compare of the Western
regions, and its daily revenue
fluctuates a lot due to the
high frequency of LiveOps.
One of the reasons behind
this is the popularity
of the gacha model.
The gacha is the
in-game lottery system
which is widely adapted to the
top grossing Japanese games
as the core
monetization mechanics.
Because gacha is a really good
fit with our limited time sales
and events, Japanese
developers run
a lot of these as a driver for
their revenue and monetization.
Of course, they are also running
a lot of other types of events,
like in-game login bonus
and the in-game quests,
but the gacha is something we
cannot ignore as an important
part of Japanese
LiveOps culture.
And another reason for
the huge fluctuation
of daily revenue in
Japan is the first day
of the month by extradition.
Japan is known as
a country where
DCB is a really popular form of
payment among the mobile users.
And as you know, DCB
has a monthly cap,
so if you keep the cap in
the middle of the month,
you have to wait until the
next first day of the month,
because the cap gets
refreshed on that day.
So knowing that timing,
Japanese developers
always bring the most
powerful LiveOps event
on the first day of the month.
And the Japanese users also
know that is the best timing
to use the money in the game.
So the combination of this
developer strategy and user
behavior actually comes
together and always causes
the huge revenue spike on the
first day of the month for most
of the games altogether, which
is pretty unique for the Japan
market, I think.
So here's a quick quiz
regarding the uniqueness
of Japanese LiveOps.
I mentioned that Japan is a
pretty LiveOps heavy market,
but how many in-game
LiveOps events were actually
run by a single top
grossing Japanese title
in the month of March 2017?
It'd be great if you guys
can participate in the quiz
by raising your hands.
Who thinks A, less than 10?
No one.
B, 10 to 50?
Thank you.
C, 50 to 100, D, 100 to 200--
looks popular-- and E, over 200.
Seems like D and E are the
most popular options here.
So let's see the answer.
The answer is E.
Congratulations for those
who chose E. Sorry, no
prize for this quiz.
[LAUGHS] No teachers, OK?
I think, now, you guys
are interested in what
the exact number is.
So let's see the exact
number in the next slide.
The answer is 1028.
Thanks for the reaction.
Yeah, over 1,000 events
in the month, which sounds
like a big number.
And this is just an example,
but now you see how serious
and how committed
Japanese games are,
regarding the communication
with the users through LiveOps.
So from here I'm
going to talk up
a bit about case studies from
actual Japanese top grossing
games, to a bit more deep dive
into their LiveOps strategies.
The first one is Monster
Strike by Mixi XFLAG Studio,
one of the most popular and
successful Japanese games
since it's launch
four years ago.
This is a quick overview
of Monster Strike's LiveOps
seen in the given months.
As you can see, they're
running 1000 LiveOps events
in the month, which
ranges from the gacha
event for monetization,
and the [INAUDIBLE]
of the in-game quest, for the
purpose of engagement uplift.
What's interesting
here to me, is
that they're running
so many system
and guerrilla events,
which are basically
an hour or a few hours long,
super short micro quests,
operated systematically.
You know, if you run 900
events in a month by manual,
you need a lot of work,
and it's almost impossible.
So Mixi actually design
the game from scratch
to be able to offer these
micro quests effectively
and efficiently by
system and automation,
so that they are able to deploy
such a large number of quests
in a month.
However, if you think about it,
if you have hundreds of LiveOps
in your game, it is
very easy for your users
to get lost if they
don't understand
what matters for them.
So it is very important for
you to organize the LiveOps
events to avoid your
users getting swamped
by the flood of LiveOps.
So from the next
slide, I'm going
to introduce to you how Mixi
actually designed the LiveOps
calendar in the yearly,
monthly and daily basis.
The first one is yearly cycle.
For a character based
game like Monster Strike,
the best content
for monetization
is always additional
legendary character
which has significant
skills and parameters.
So Mixi basically runs this
type of flagship, heavy LiveOps
gacha events every three months,
considering the seasonality
and so on.
According to Mixi,
the once in three
months is kind of a magic
number from their four years'
experience, because if users
are exposed too frequently
to this type of heavy events,
they get tired of catching up,
and they eventually
leave the game.
So rather than increasing the
number of these heavy LiveOps
events, Mixi rather focuses on
maximizing the revenue spike
for each of them.
And zooming into
the monthly cycle,
Monster Strike generally
has a consistent beat
of revenue spike in
a bi-weekly basis.
This is because
they are following
the first day of the month spike
tradition in the Japan market,
and also place a mid-size
LiveOps is in between these,
to keep your core users engaged.
Precisely speaking, they
are actually running
a lot of other events in between
these, but that they stick
to this cadence with
a strong gacha event
to keep the good
rhythm of excitement
for their core users,
which is especially
for the paying users.
And they also care
a lot about when
to deploy, what kind
of events in a day,
from the relevancy
point of view.
For example, they deploy
the gacha events typically
around lunchtime, because
they want their users who just
got a new character
through the gacha,
to show off that to
your real friends
who are eating their
lunch together,
and who hopefully play
the game together.
And on the other hand,
regarding the quests that
require some level
of concentration,
they typical deploy these around
commit time, or after dinner,
when users typically
play the game alone
with a lot of concentration.
So in these ways Mixi is
carefully designing the LiveOps
calendar to help
their users enjoy
surfing on the various sides
of the webs of the LiveOps.
So now let's do a bit more deep
dive into one of the flagship
LiveOps events, which happens
only once in three months.
The example here is
a special gacha event
which featured the new
legendary character called
Pandora, this cute girl.
And this event was especially
successful for Mixi
because it drove 150% year
over year increase in revenue.
So let's take a look at Mixi's
efforts behind this big moment.
The first one is quantity
control of in-game currencies
owned by users.
When you have a
huge monetization
moment in your game
in terms of LiveOps,
it is very important
to create an idea
of the status of the
in-game economy beforehand.
For example, if
users have too many
unconsumed in-game
currencies already,
they just spend these
when LiveOps come in,
and they don't really
purchase new IAP,
which could be a problem
for your monetization.
So Mixi actually tracks the
quantity of in-game currency
that is owned by users as
one of the key metrics,
and accumulated a small LiveOps
before the flagship gacha
event, and created an ideal
or state of in-game economy
prior to that big monetization
moment for the game.
And also they went
beyond in-game operations
and added out of the
game, media mix activities
to promote the LiveOps event.
For example, this
character Pandora
was introduced first in the
YouTube anime of Monster Strike
three days before the
actual in-game event,
and then the details
of the characters,
like skills and
the parameters, got
revealed in their in-house
influencer video on YouTube.
And then every TV
commercial wants
aired to promote this
LiveOps campaign after that.
I know it sounds like
a lot of investment,
but for Mixi, actually it
was a really natural thing,
because they are
putting it at the center
of their monetization strategy.
And even more, they added
several significant marketing
activities before the
Pandora gacha event,
which includes a massive
giveaway of in-game items,
and even real goods,
like a travel ticket,
to the active users
of Monster Strike
during the holiday seasons.
And also the large scale
fan community event
in the e-sports
tournament, which
gathered over 20,000
people in Tokyo on site.
These marketing activities
were not directly
related to this
specific gacha event,
but were strategically
placed before that,
to maximize to active user
base, to make the big monetizing
moment of that.
So what's the result
by doing all of these?
So here's a chart you
would be interested in.
Actually, Monster Strike had
been facing this steep decline
of the monthly active user base
for the first half of 2016.
However, by providing a good
mix of in-game operations
and out of game
marketing activities,
they could achieve the
beautiful reshaped recovery
of monthly active
users, and it resulted
in the great financial success
of the Pandora gacha event
after that.
When talking about
LiveOps, people
tend to focus too much on
just the in-game activities,
but actually it drives to
more impact on your business
it's nicely branded with out
of game marketing activities.
So this is a very
good example, I think.
So that was the Pandora
gacha event example.
And let me talk about
some other cases as well.
When talking about Japan's
unique LiveOps culture,
IP collaboration is
something I cannot ignore,
which is very popular
among Japanese developers.
For example, collaboration with
popular games' IP, comic IP,
anime IP, is very popular
among Japanese games,
because it is very effective
to bring the new surprise
to your existing
audience base, and also
reach out to the entirely
new audience space
through the power
of the different IP.
And this kind of
collaboration can also
happen with non-game
offline brands as well.
This is my favorite example,
but Monster Strike actually
collaborated with
Baskin-Robbins [INAUDIBLE],,
a popular ice cream franchise
store, and they actually
created a special
quest in the game,
and the when users
completed the quest,
they could get a free ice
cream coupon inside the game.
And if I'm not biased, everyone
loves ice cream, right?
So actually Monster
Strike could make
their users happy by
giving away free ice cream,
and in return, Baskin-Robbins
could drive the actual people
to the store, and even
enhance their brand awareness
with this.
This case is quite
interesting to me,
because it shows me how wide
the scope of LiveOps is.
If it makes sense for
you and your partner,
you can even distribute your
ice cream through your users
in the context of LiveOps.
So that was the Mixi case.
And I'd like to introduce
you to another case,
from the other Japanese
developer, KLab,
and the game is
BLEACH: Brave Souls.
When designing LiveOps,
taking a data driven approach
is really effective
and important.
So here I'd like to
introduce to you how
sophisticated developers
at KLab are designing
effective LiveOps, based
on the insights gained
through the in-game
data log analytics.
This slide shows the basic
KPIs that the KLab analytics
team is looking at, which
includes monetization KPI,
[INAUDIBLE] revenue, and the
ARPPU, and engagement KPIs,
like churn rate, and
the new user KPIs,
including installs and
seven-day retention.
To extract key insights, the
KLab analytics team actually
look at these KPIs from four
different user segmentation
angles, which includes
in game status,
install timing, login
frequency, and spend range.
Here I'd like to introduce to
you one interesting case, where
a KLab team found very good
insight looking at the in game
status segmentation.
So BLEACH: Brave Souls has a
character build-up function,
called a skill board.
And the KLab team found that the
combination of this skill board
progression and the maximum
rarity of the character
that the users own is actually
one of the best angles
to look at the health status
of the overall in-game balance.
When they look at
key engagement KPIs
from this user
segmentation angle,
they found that the users
who own the six-star rarity
character, but hasn't completed
the skill board yet, actually
has a significant
churn rate compared
with other groups of users.
And even worse,
this group of people
represented over 20%
of the total consumer
spend for this game.
So it was a problem.
So to solve this problem,
KLab added new quests
that helped users to complete
the six-star still board
easily.
And by doing so, the users
who complete the skill board
and go up to the
next level actually
increased from 4% to
9.7% month over month.
And even significantly,
the churn rate
of this specific group
decreased by 11.8%,
compared from the
previous months.
As I said, this group
of users represented
the 20% of the total
consumer spend, so now you
see how impactful it was for
the BLEACH: Brave Souls team.
So it was quick, but I hope
you enjoyed some fresh case
studies shared from the
Mixi and the KLab teams.
So now I'd like to summarize
today's key takeaways
from these case studies.
So here's four key
pillars I talked today.
The first one is LiveOps design.
So if you want to make
the most out of LiveOps,
you have to design your
game with LiveOps in mind.
I think Mixi's system
event functionality
is one of the great
examples of doing this.
And also, you have to design
a strategic cycle of LiveOps,
if you would like to
run a lot of LiveOps.
Otherwise your users get
swamped by the flood of LiveOps.
And also the control
of in-game economy,
which is very important.
So you shouldn't
forget about it.
And the third, go
beyond simple LiveOps.
When talking about
LiveOps, people
tend to focus too much on
just in-game activities.
But when it's nicely
branded with out of the game
marketing activities, you can
actually generate more impact
on your business.
And the collaboration
with other IPs and brands
could be an interesting
idea for you,
if you want to reach out to an
entirely new audience space.
And lastly, user
behavior is always
a great source of insights.
So if you want to be really
effective and efficient
in creating new LiveOps
events for your game,
taking a data driven approach
would work pretty well for you.
OK.
So thanks for listening.
That's all for me today.
So if you have any questions
I would like to take these.